[Music]
it's up y'all my name's Nick for the
poorest thing being brothers I said it
would be awesome I would do whatever it
takes to get into this Fred I'm a quick
making lifelong friend whatever it takes
gentlemen welcome to sai theta epsilon
one of the oldest most prestigious
fraternities in America
the man you see standing beside you will
become your best friend for life if you
trust me ask any member here this
program works make no mistake about it
this is not gonna be easy some people in
this frat that are gonna make it as hard
as possible I know that if you stick
together and trust each other that you
will work through it I can't wait to
call you guys my brothers
[Music]
working on a new film project it's a
documentary about fraternity hazing
people are dying this pew caught us on
tape doing some illicit things
[Music]
I'm gonna change anything right what
they don't seem to understand that when
they send us underground it only makes
us more and more rabbit
we talk about Brotherhood you work for
it you've got a hunger for it you've got
a launch dye and bleed for it welcome to
hell
[Music]
what does brother it means you
it's an unbreakable bond than you have
for a rest your letter
[Music]
you